las bayas que hacen homenaje a los
soldados que combaten en el frente de
batalla parecen ser el único rastro de
la guerra que se libra cientos de
kilómetros de distancia de poblaciones
ubicadas en el oeste de ucrania
pero esta familia recuerda que el dolor
se extiende por todo el país
volodomir es uno de los tantos jóvenes
que se alistaron el mismo día que rusia
comenzó la invasión el 24 de febrero
irene su madre cuenta que algunos de los
amigos lo intentaron convencer de que se
esperara unos días y se uniera
posteriormente a las fuerzas especiales
pero él quiso integrarse de inmediato
murió a comienzos de marzo cuando
realizaban una operación en el norte de
ucrania tenía 26 años desde entonces su
familia incluida su prometida olga
intentan aprender a vivir con sus
recuerdos con un juego año con cada
funeral perdemos más esperanza
y tengo mucho pensar que hombres tan
jóvenes se estén muriendo
el gobierno de ucrania no publica las
cifras de los soldados muertos pero el
presidente volodomir selenski dijo que
en la batalla por la región del donbass
en el este del país más de 200
combatientes morían diariamente
artista iván también recuerda su hijo
artem que murió en el frente el 18 de
junio ha podido recuperar el libro de
zénica que lo había acompañado hasta la
guerra
looking to to harmony
él buscaba la armonía armonizar sus
sentimientos no es fácil matar gente
cuando se tiene 27 años
antes era la pasión de artem era la
historia pero también el paracaidismo se
encontraba en un viaje de aventura
cuando comenzó la guerra y no dudó en
regresar y enlistarse como voluntarios
recibió un mensaje en el que me decían
que lo sentían mucho que algo terrible
había pasado pero yo no sabía quién
llamé de vuelta y le pregunté al hombre
quién es porque tengo dos hijos en la
guerra
su terapia seguir pintando para
exorcizar la tristeza de la pérdida y la
angustia no saber el estado de su otro
hijo pero cree que no es tiempo de
llorar sino de apoyarse entre todos los
ucranianos